does penis size matter to you
no so you wouldn't turn away someone had
like a micro penis goodness no is this
your way of telling me
no i'm good
i'm good why do you ask it's not for
your own
deal breakers weird stuff like oh i want
multiple partners or i don't know i like
dogging or do you want to dress up as a
cat i think if they are like hanging out
with the boys like every single night
that's probably a bit of a red flag to
me like that boys mentality sorry
when you meet someone you can kind of
get a picture of like whether you kind
of want to be with them i'm quite quick
to sort of just say yeah no i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna jump in
hey hi
how's it going good how are you stand up
but yeah covered in think about this
thing how's it going i'm good how are
you yeah good thank you good ladies
first we can rock paper scissors it's
totally up to you
and yeah i'm happy to go first cool
what is the first thing that you noticed
about me when i walked in
uh i think you got really like blue eyes
yeah like very blue thank you
yeah i grew them
what's the first thing you notice about
me the british accent
yeah okay mine's got a little bit of
south african stuck in there yeah i have
no idea
yeah yeah very much so oh you reckon
that sounded really australian yeah i
mean there we go you reckon yeah
am i the best looking person you've been
on a date with
no
but i say that because i have come from
sydney beaches so the blonde surfer hair
look is usually what i've sort of
gotten towards right but you're quite
handsome
it's good yeah
yeah i'll take it i'll take it it'll
take we can get these days would you say
i have one of the
most handsome people
good looking anything i say now is just
going to sound really petty but and
hopefully all so nice but i don't know
if i've got like a real reason for it um
like i don't have like a cool story of
like surfers on beaches
you don't have to you don't have to
explain yourself that's fine i'm
confident in my own appearance so cool
yeah
feelings yeah that's good that's
attractive as well
does body count matter to you
not really
because everyone's got a past like i'm
no saint myself
so i think it should kind of be about
going forward yeah good answer
good answer and yourself
i wouldn't say it matters a number i
think just sort of the attitude about it
so i think you've gone the right way
about it that's interesting okay cool
yeah i couldn't care less how many
people you start with it's more if you
feel like you need to judge someone
because of it so i see okay cool i
actually don't think i have a number no
it's not like a crazy amount that i've
lost count but like
sort of under 10 under 10. okay do you
have a number i've never really kind of
counted i think i've just kind of just
gone with it i i'm too disorganized to
count and make lists and things yeah no
it's good it's a good way to go about it
so i don't think i've ever really done
it i think somewhere around maybe like
50
going in that area yeah cool i mean i
guess it doesn't matter either way sorry
mom
i know my mom's gonna be like
does penis size matter to you
no no i think that would be very
shallow if i was to say yes yeah so you
wouldn't turn away someone had like a
micro penis goodness no is this your way
of telling me
no i'm good
i'm good
no because that's really horrible and i
have flaws myself and if someone was to
turn me away for that i'd
i wouldn't want anything to do with them
yeah it's a good answer not that it
affects me but why do you ask
it's not for your own
i think like guys banter about it no one
gets to choose so
exactly yeah i don't even do about that
have you ever had an sti
um no
growing up in south africa we do have an
issue with hiv
in that country so
everyone views sex like as safe as
possible cool because when i
when we were when i was like reading
over these questions i was like oh my
gosh i can ask that comfortably knowing
that i don't but i don't want to put
someone on the spot to sort of
answer that so i'm glad that it was that
answer for the sake of not
yeah
putting you in a position to answer no
so i don't wanna yeah i didn't really
think about it in the sense of
if the answer was yes then like maybe
that would be a bit uncomfortable for
you to talk about so okay yeah
yeah that was always a bit apprehensive
to ask sexually healthy people right
yeah
that's always good watch out
would you describe any of your exes as
being crazy
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah is there a follow-up um yeah do you
think it has something to do with the
way you traded them to get there at the
time i was a very different person you
know um i was in university at this
stage
i was a little bit loose
and i think she knew that kind of going
into the relationship and i think that
knowledge like she wasn't completely uh
trusting in me from the get-go
that was crazy so crazy
[Music]
interesting and yourself
not crazy
like
i think when things end there's always
like heightened emotions and things sort
of
for someone it's always a little bit
harder of a breakup than the other but i
wouldn't necessarily call any of them
crazy
so why did you ask that question
i think it's a reflection
sometimes on
the male in the relationship like you
hear about people like guys saying like
oh girls are so crazy and it's it's
often it's like a cop out well so it's
often the boy that's led them to getting
crazy like sometimes they're just sort
of like unaware that maybe their actions
are
making the girls i always think of like
jealous people it's like why are you so
jealous the whole time what are you
hiding yes but then it's also like their
partner is probably doing things that
yeah they know is gonna make them
jealous or crazy or whatever so yeah i
think it's sort of a bit of a reflection
on both people in the relationship
but you you've admitted that as well you
said like there we go you're a bit
looser whatever that means
so yeah
would you ever tell your partner not to
wear something
no
oh i mean unless it was like super weird
weird i don't know like if we were like
going out somewhere like i know they put
on a cat costume why the hell are you
wearing a cat costume okay that's not
like that like take that off it's weird
don't wear pajamas to a wedding yeah
okay cool so in like a sensible sort of
rational way yeah exactly not in like a
controlling like why are you leaving the
house without me wearing that kind of
thing no
cool so i've been with people that have
said that really yeah i've had partners
who have said like as if you would wear
that like the disrespect that you would
wear that out without me oh okay yes
just trust someone i don't dress for
other people's attention i just like for
yourself for myself
yeah other people aren't porn no
have you ever asked me not to wear
anything out no i guess like it's it's
pretty hard for a guy i think to dress
like in a sense that would offend anyone
so i think so so like brunch in the
mankini is out of there it's not
happening i mean if you want to because
we've got to set these boundaries out
we've got to know it's important yeah i
mean if you want if you want to whip it
out and wear that down to right
then that's on you
you can live with that i might just be
lying on the rocks a couple couple
meters over
yeah no
i don't think that's gonna happen yeah
maybe well i don't know
have you ever cheated
oh when i was 13 and in a serious
relationship at 13 like how serious can
it be like yeah those ones are hectic
but
i will say that i learned a lot from it
at 13. definitely what did you learn
from it like i think it was just really
in the moment thing
and it sort of just taught me
you know yeah to think about yourself
yeah 13 like who like seriously have you
ever cheated on someone i've never
cheated on someone no i've like a lot of
sisters like i kind of saw what happened
um and how like people yeah reacted it
was obviously like it's not good you
ever been cheated on i mean not my
knowledge yeah do you know what i mean
yeah i mean hopefully not if so i'd like
to live and bless her ignorance yeah um
that's cool yeah
what matters more to you is it looks or
is it personality personality
personality it's true 100 100 i couldn't
give a [ __ ] what you look like that's
good i mean so we don't have to worry
about the fact that i'm not the most
attractive guy i've been on date it's
all about personality so that's good
would you say looks or personality
personality i think they both have their
importance one is more like i know
opening the door the other one is being
inside the home yeah no it's a good
answer
so you wouldn't ask me on a date
because i'm i'm not the most attractive
person or if that's a good thing
no like yeah it means that that one i
would still ask you on a date cool even
though yeah so i still have a chance
[Laughter]
even though i'm not the most attractive
girl
we're gonna we're gonna stick on this
yeah this is this is i'll never let you
live that down now i'll never let you
live there
i could have your first point
so will there be a second date
are you gonna rock paper scissors this
or
oh okay i'll i'll have the balls i'll
say it yeah i would go on another date
with you yeah
interesting getting to know you and
we seem like we have similar similar
attitudes about a lot of the things that
we've asked so yeah our back and side as
well
i just feel like i always attract nyx
every time they're like nick i'm like
she was really nice straight away her
her eyes caught in there extremely blue
he seems like a genuine person i'm
interested to see how it goes without
cameras there's no reason to go into it
with anything other than optimism
is liking another girl's instagram photo
cheating no
just like do you think there's anywhere
yes yeah no instagram is literally like
you're flicking you're flicking and you
just double tap
it's literally not real life